problem number six let f of X is equal
to sine of x squared plus cosine of X
the graph of y is equal to the absolute
value of the fifth derivative of f at X
is shown above and I haven't shown it
here too so we have some space I'll I'll
show it when we need to show it I think
we have to show it in Part D so first
let's do Part A right over here right
the first nonzero terms for the Taylor
series of for sine of X about X is equal
to zero and write the four first four
nonzero terms of the Taylor series for
sine of x squared about x equals zero so
let's do this first part and just a
reminder a Taylor series is a polynomial
approximation of a function so just as a
just to give us a quick reminder we go
into much more detail in this on the
videos about Taylor series but if you
have a function that looks like this and
if you wanted to approximate it with the
Taylor series around zero you could if
you only have one term in your Taylor
series you would you would just least
have it it would just be a constant just
like that if you have two terms in your
Taylor series it would be a line that
looks like that if you have three terms
in your Taylor series you'd get to a
second degree term and you'd start
approximating it something like that if
you have if you get to the third degree
term it might start looking like that
and as you add more and more terms you
get it a better a better approximation
of your function and if you add an
infinite number it might actually
converge to your function so let's just
remind ourselves if I have a function if
I have f of X its Taylor series I can
approximate it with this Taylor series
and if we want to if we want to Center
that approximation around zero
it'll be equal to f of 0 plus F prime of
0 the derivative at 0 times X plus the
second derivative at 0 times x squared
over 2 factorial you could've divided
this term right here by 1 factorial
which is just 1 2 factorial is just 2
and then plus the third derivative of f
at 0 times X to the third over 3
factorial plus the fourth derivative
idea here at the fourth derivative at 0
times X to the fourth divided by 4
factorial and so on and so forth
so what they want to do is find the
first four nonzero terms of the Taylor
series for sine of X and some some of
you might already know this week
covered this in the video where we show
Oilers Euler's identity but we'll do it
again right over here so if you would if
we just take well let's just take I'll
call it G of X because they already
defined f of X up here so let's say that
G of X we're just in a new color just to
ease the monotony let's say let's say
that G of X is equal to sine of X then
we know that G of 0 is going to be equal
to 0 and let and then if we take the
derivative G prime of X is going to be
equal to negative I know it's going to
be positive cosine of X positive cosine
of X G prime of 0 is now going to be
equal to 1 cosine of 0 is 1 and if you
take the second derivative the
derivative of cosine of X is negative
sine of X negative sine of X and the
second derivative at 0 once again is
going to be equal 0 sine of 0 0 and now
let's take the third derivative third
derivative at the third derivative our
function of G the derivative of negative
sine of X is negative cosine of X and
the third derivative at 0 is now going
to be equal to negative 1 and then we
could keep going you can already guess
where this is where this might lead to
but I'll just keep going just in case
the fourth derivative is once again
going to be equal to sine of X is now
going to be equal to sine of X and then
the fourth derivative the fourth
derivative at 0 because it's the same
thing as the function is now going to be
0 as well so this is going to be equal
to G the fourth at 0 and then we can
keep going this is going to be the same
thing as G to the fifth because we start
cycling as we take more and more
derivatives so this is going to be the
same thing as the fifth derivative at 0
this is going to be the same thing as
the sixth derivative the sixth
derivative at 0 and this is going to be
the same thing this is going to be the
same this is an equal sign right here
equals 1 and this is going to be the
same thing as the seventh derivative at
0 so if you want the first four if you
want the first four nonzero terms let's
just work through it so first of all f
of zero
I'll do this in a new color
if we want to approximate G of X if we
want to approximate sine of X so we'll
say sine of X is going to be
approximately equal to so this first
term right over here that is sine of
zero that's G of zero that's going to be
zero so we don't even have to write it
then we go to this term right over here
well the first derivative F Prime at 0
in this case G prime of 0 is going to be
equal to 1 so it's going to be 1 times X
so you're going to have an X there then
the next term is going to be a 0 that's
going to be a 0 we see that right over
there
because F the second derivative of our
function evaluated at 0 is 0 our third
derivative of our function evaluated at
0 is 1 so that term is going to show up
again that actually that term is
negative 1 I don't wanna make a mistake
here that is negative 1 negative 1 it
was negative cosine of X you evaluate
negative cosine of X at 0 you get
negative 1 right over here so the third
derivative this thing right over here is
negative 1 so then we have minus X to
the third over 3 factorial the fourth
derivative once again is 0 the fifth
derivative evaluated at 0 is 1 so then
you're going to have plus 1 times X to
the fifth over 5 factorial then the
sixth derivative is 0 so that term is
going to disappear I didn't even write
it up here and then the 7th term the
coefficient is negative 1 or the 7th
derivative evaluated 0 is negative once
you have negative 1 times X to the
seventh over 7 factorial and that we
have to go all the way to the seventh
degree term to find the first four
nonzero terms for our Taylor series and
so we're done with at least the first
part we found the first not the first
four nonzero terms of sine of X now what
about sine squared of X or sine sine of
x squared we have to be careful here
because you might just say okay let me
just apply this formula and we're gonna
find very quickly is when you start
taking the second and third derivatives
of this thing right over here it's going
to get really messy but what you can say
is look sine of X is approximately this
thing right over here what happens if I
just replace the X with the x squared
then I get sine of x squared then I get
sine of x squared is approximately equal
to instead of
next year I'm going to put the x-squared
instead of an X to the third here I'm
going to put an x squared to the third
over here over three factorial instead
of an X to the fifth I can put an x
squared to the fifth power over five
factorial and instead of an X to the
seventh I could write x squared to the
seventh power over seven factorial so
this is this is a very important thing
to realize because if you had if you
started directly take the the Taylor
series around zero of this thing right
here you have taken up all your time
trying to take the derivatives and you
probably wouldn't have been able to do
it anyway because we've gotten really
messy and the key here is just to
realize that if you just if you
substitute x squared for X you're then
going to get your you're then going to
get the approximation for sine of x
squared we could simplify this a little
bit this is going to be approximately
equal to x squared minus X to the sixth
over three factorial plus X to the tenth
over five factorial minus X to the 14th
over seven factorial so that's our
second part of the problem